Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Five: the Danish flag, and the royal house.
The Danish national flag, Dannebrog, is a white cross on a red background.
Dannebrog means "the Danes' banner" or "the red-coloured banner".
Even though the legend tells that Dannebrog fell down from the sky during a military battle in Estonia in 1219 and secured the Danes the victory, the flag is in reality probably a banner that was already used by the knights who went on crusades in the Middle Ages.
Dannebrog is regarded as one of the world's oldest national flags and has since the 1400s been used as a banner when Danish kings went to war.
Through the 1600s and 1700s, it was only the authorities and the navy that used the Danish national flag.
But from the middle of the 1800s, it became popular among the population to fly the flag.
Today many Danes fly Dannebrog on festive occasions, for example a private birthday or an official day of observance.
The flag is also used at funerals, where the flag is only raised halfway up the flagpole until the funeral has taken place.
On certain dates all public authorities must fly the flag.
They must for example do so at church festivals, and when members of the royal family have birthdays.
Many companies and private persons also mark these days by raising Dannebrog.
Historical days of observance are also marked by flying Dannebrog.
This applies, for example, to Denmark's liberation on the fifth of May, and Constitution Day, grundlovsdag, on the fifth of June.
In Denmark it is not allowed to fly other countries' flags than the Danish without permission from the police.
You may, however, fly the flag of Greenland, the flag of the Faroe Islands, the other Nordic countries' flags, and the UN flag and the EU flag without the police's permission.
Denmark's best-known order, a medal, the Order of the Dannebrog, Dannebrogordenen, is named after the Danish flag.
It is awarded by the king to senior civil servants, politicians, cultural figures, military people, prominent business people and researchers who have made a special effort to promote Denmark's interests.
Now, the royal house, Kongehuset.
The Danish royal house is among the oldest of the world's total of 43 monarchies.
It is over a thousand years old and can with certainty be traced back to Gorm the Old in the 900s.
From and including him, Denmark has had a total of 54 monarchs: 52 kings and two queens.
From 1448 to 1863, Denmark was ruled by the Oldenburg family, and afterwards by the Glücksburg family, which has the same ancestors as the Oldenburgs.
Denmark's present monarch is King Frederik the Tenth, born 1968, who belongs to this family.
He succeeded his mother Queen Margrethe the Second, who chose to abdicate on the fourteenth of January 2024, the same date in 1972 on which she herself took over the throne at her father Frederik the Ninth's death.
Since 1448, when the Oldenburg family took over the throne, 20 of 21 Danish kings have, by the way, been called either Christian or Frederik.
Denmark is a constitutional monarchy.
That means the monarchy works within the framework of the constitution and democracy.
The monarch, the king or queen, is not politically elected, but inherits the throne.
The king has no real political power.
He does not interfere in political life, does not express political views and cannot, conversely, be held responsible for the government.
A number of the king's formal tasks are however connected to political life.
He takes part, among other things, in the opening of the Folketing on the first Tuesday of October and takes part when ministers are to be appointed or a new government formed.
The king signs the laws passed by the Folketing and the government together with the politically responsible minister.
This takes place at the Council of State, statsråd, at Christiansborg, where the king meets with the government's ministers.
The king is also host when Denmark receives state visits, and he represents the country at state visits abroad.
The king also carries out a long series of other formal and representative tasks in Denmark.
The king and the royal house are a national rallying point.
The royal house has a central place in Danes' history and is very popular among the population.
Many follow, for example on TV, when the monarch on New Year's Eve gives his traditional speech from the royal family's home at Amalienborg in Copenhagen or from the residence at Fredensborg Palace, Fredensborg Slot, outside Copenhagen.
Amalienborg is the royal family's home; Christiansborg is where the Council of State, statsråd, meets.
And many turn up at Amalienborg Palace Square and cheer the king on his birthday, which is the 26th of May.
The king has since 2004 been married to Queen Mary, born 1972, who originally comes from Australia.
Together they have four children: Crown Prince Christian, born 2005, Princess Isabella, born 2007, and the twins Prince Vincent and Princess Josephine, born 2011.
The eldest, Crown Prince Christian, will one day take over the throne as Christian the Eleventh.
Here is your recap for Episode Five.
Dannebrog is a white cross on a red background and means "the Danes' banner" or "the red-coloured banner".
The legend says it fell from the sky in Estonia in 1219.
It is regarded as one of the world's oldest national flags and has been used as a royal banner since the 1400s.
At funerals the flag is flown at half mast.
Without police permission you may only fly the flags of Greenland, the Faroe Islands, the Nordic countries, the UN and the EU.
The Order of the Dannebrog is Denmark's best-known order.
The Danish royal house is among the oldest of the world's 43 monarchies, traceable to Gorm the Old in the 900s.
Denmark has had 54 monarchs, 52 kings and two queens.
The Oldenburgs ruled 1448 to 1863, then the Glücksburgs.
King Frederik the Tenth, born 1968, succeeded his mother Margrethe the Second, who abdicated on the fourteenth of January 2024.
The king's birthday is the 26th of May.
On nytårsaften, New Year's Eve, the monarch, today the king, gives the traditional speech to the whole realm; older exams say the queen; it is not Christmas Eve or Constitution Day.
Liberation Day, the fifth of May, and Constitution Day, the fifth of June, are both flag days.
He has been married to Queen Mary, from Australia, since 2004, and they have four children, with Crown Prince Christian the eldest.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
What is the eldest son of Crown Prince Frederik and Crown Princess Mary called?
Option A: Gorm.
Option B: Harald.
Option C: Christian.
[DA] Hvad hedder Kronprins Frederik og Kronprinsesse Marys ældste søn?  A: Gorm  |  B: Harald  |  C: Christian
The answer is C: Christian.
It appeared in the June 2020 and November 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Christian
Question 2.
In which year did Margrethe the Second become queen of Denmark?
Option A: 1972.
Option B: 1982.
Option C: 1992.
[DA] Hvilket år blev Margrethe d. 2. dronning af Danmark?  A: 1972  |  B: 1982  |  C: 1992
The answer is A: 1972.
It appeared in the June 2022 and May 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: 1972
Question 3.
Who became Denmark's new king in January 2024?
Option A: Frederik the Fourth.
Option B: Frederik the Seventh.
Option C: Frederik the Tenth.
[DA] Hvem blev Danmarks nye konge i januar 2024?  A: Frederik den 4.  |  B: Frederik den 7.  |  C: Frederik den 10.
The answer is C: Frederik the Tenth.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Frederik den 10.
Question 4.
Which country does Queen Mary originally come from?
Option A: Canada.
Option B: Great Britain.
Option C: Australia.
[DA] Hvilket land kommer dronning Mary oprindeligt fra?  A: Canada  |  B: Storbritannien  |  C: Australien
The answer is C: Australia.
It appeared in the May 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Australien
Question 5.
In which castle in Copenhagen does the king and his family live part of the year?
Option A: Christiansborg.
Option B: Rosenborg.
Option C: Amalienborg.
[DA] På hvilket slot i København bor kongen og hans familie en del af året?  A: Christiansborg  |  B: Rosenborg  |  C: Amalienborg
The answer is C: Amalienborg.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Amalienborg
Question 6.
Which of the following castles is one of the royal family's residences outside Copenhagen?
The exam says Queen Margrethe's residences.
Option A: Egeskov Castle.
Option B: Fredensborg Castle.
Option C: Kronborg Castle.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende slotte er en af Dronning Margrethes residenser udenfor København?  A: Egeskov Slot  |  B: Fredensborg Slot  |  C: Kronborg Slot
The answer is B: Fredensborg Castle.
It appeared in the June 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Fredensborg Slot
Question 7.
Which day of observance is celebrated on the fifth of June?
Option A: The Queen's birthday.
Option B: Denmark's liberation.
Option C: Constitution Day.
[DA] Hvilken mærkedag fejres den 5. juni?  A: Dronningens fødselsdag  |  B: Danmarks befrielse  |  C: Grundlovsdag
The answer is C: Constitution Day.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Grundlovsdag
Question 8.
On which date is Denmark's liberation in 1945, after five years of German occupation, marked?
Option A: The eighth of March.
Option B: The ninth of April.
Option C: The fifth of May.
[DA] På hvilken dato markeres Danmarks befrielse i 1945 efter fem års tysk besættelse?  A: 8. marts  |  B: 9. april  |  C: 5. maj
The answer is C: The fifth of May.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: 5. maj
That's the end of this part.
Well done.